bonsoir première journée de
reconstitution du meurtre de grégory
villemin les mêmes acteurs bernard
laroche en moins mais de nouveaux
magistrats après le petit juge le grand
magistrat mort estime le président de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de dijon était aujourd'hui à lépanges
trois ans après on se pose toujours la
même question
christine villemin aurait-elle eu
matériellement le temps d'accomplir ce
crime de notre station de nancy didier
bouillot une longue attente puis une
série de courses poursuites entre les
penche sur vologne à docelles c'est
ainsi que s'est déroulée la première
après-midi de cette reconstitution
tous les acteurs de ce nouvel épisode de
la sphère grégory se sont retrouvés peu
après 14 heures à la mairie de lépanges
jean marie et christine villemin
leurs parents leurs avocats et la
chambre d'accusation de la cour d'appel
de dijon au grand complet maître
d'oeuvre le président simon en charge du
dossier depuis mars dernier qui entend
vérifier minutieusement toutes les
hypothèses pour établir sa conviction
quant au déroulement de cet après midi
du 16 octobre 84 sa première étape
contrôler la crédibilité de l'accusation
qui pèse contre christine en répondant à
cette question at elle eu le temps de
commettre le crime les chronométrages
effectuées par les policiers dans cl le
laissaient penser les allers-retours
effectués aujourd'hui par un convoi de
voitures de gendarmes suivie par une
cohorte de journalistes devaient
permettre à maurice simon de vérifier
cette base les itinéraires possibles les
lieux présumés ou grégory auraient été
jetés dans la vologne l'endroit où il a
été retrouvé
rien n'a été laissé au hasard pas même
les autres hypothèses puisque ce matin
dès leurs premiers reconnaissance les
magistrats se sont arrêtés en des points
éloignés de la maison des villemin des
points constituant un excellent poste
d'observation
là c'est la thèse de la défense que le
magistrat instructeur avait en tête une
thèse qui reviendrait au premier plan si
les chronométrages effectué cet après
midi ils ne sentaient christine villemin
dès demain le président simon fera
entrer en scène les témoins qui se
trouvaient sur ces parcours il les a
tous entendu la semaine dernière à dijon
il en a revu ce matin
comme cette voisine qui a vu christine
hulne a remonté chez elle vers 17 heures
le jour du drame
à tous le magistrat demandera de se
souvenir car pour tous c'est cette
semaine que l' affaire grégory doit
trouver sa conclusion ou prendre un
nouveau départ